well yeah
yeah this is a good sign
this is a good sign this is going to
keep people active for the car
grease
well well well well well
well well well well okay
so first heard about this uh
specifically
about how snyder cut apparently stream
more than end game
because our friend tyrone magnus put up
a video they had it in the title and i
was like what what's he talking about
so then um what we ended up doing was
looking up the articles here's what's
going on
very recently zack snyder said that
warner brothers has been aggressively
anti-snyder
and yet in china it has crossed over
250 million views in migu video
which is a chinese streaming platform
it's one of the biggest
probably the most popular in china i
think it is and it beat avengers end
game making it
the most streamed superhero movie
essentially in the world and uh
wb still aggressively anti-snyder now
you might have seen some of our previous
videos by this point we just did a
couple in the last couple weeks
where we've gone really into depth about
why we think they should restore the
snyder verse how ridiculous we think it
is
wb it doesn't even seem to be
considering
avenues on what to do that's probably
like the most annoying thing is like
after they release that justice league
4k trailers like they're really trying
to bury this
aren't they and more than just the fact
that they like we've already talked so
much about how great the numbers are
doing they've already doubled the
numbers i kind of wanted to hone in a
little bit more on what zack snyder said
because this is
kind of the dilemma that echoes the
voice of the fans of him
john why don't you read it so zack was
recently on
jake's takes what's that guy's name i
don't know
jake hamilton i think jake hamilton
you've seen his face before he was
talking to zack snyder recently and he
asked basically if schneider cut fans
should maintain any type of hope
zack had this to say i would think about
it this way yes
warner bros has been aggressively
anti-snyder if you will and that's
what can you say what can i say clearly
there's they are not interested in my
take but i would also say that they
certainly weren't interested in my take
on justice league they certainly made
decisions about that and i loved the
characters and i loved the worlds
and i think it's an amazing place to
make a movie it's a glorious ip
so there's that i don't know what could
be done as you go forward other than i
think the fan movement is so strong and
the fan community is so
the intention is so pure and i really
have a huge respect for it i would hope
that cooler heads would prevail with
warner bros
and that they would see that there's
this massive fandom that wants more of
that but
who knows what they'll do i actually did
hear the audio of when he said it and it
does
feel a little bit like
he himself has lost hope that this could
even happen
i don't know i don't know because this
question was phrased to him about
should fans maintain hope and it didn't
exactly say
yes or no yeah any and any of this
basically just saying like i'm kind of
with the fans on this one
warner brothers doesn't like what i want
to do warner bros doesn't like what we
did but the fan movement
is really powerful and passionate and
strong so it's like yeah
you're echoing kind of the sentiment
that we have specifically for the kind
of films that he makes you know
yeah the sad part is is like i really
want them to figure out some way to work
with restoring the snyder verse in some
capacity i do not agree
with what like recently james gunn was
having actually a back and forth with
someone on instagram
who was attacking him and kind of
putting some blame on him for why the
snyder verses and get like that kind of
[ __ ] i don't agree with i'm like you
don't need to do that the pretense or
the mindset that i think you can
still kind of make this all work you can
still have james going to do the suicide
squad
you know like i'm still really looking
forward to that movie but then you got
this side of the spectrum here where
to be okay i'll just be honest i'm
starting to lose hope
that that's the sad part for me i i will
not give up and i will always champion
for it
and the sad part is is i i myself am at
a point there's already comments i know
of like
let it go guys why are we still talking
about this all that jazz
then there's that other part of me
that's like but we fought for the snyder
cut and that happened
it's a different case and it took years
it took years it was filmed
all right like for the most part most 99
of it was filmed already
and then they just had to do all the
post-production stuff mainly to to get
it made so it's different than like
write a new script you know start
filming some of the whole new movie you
know do all this let's change the plans
at the dc avenue because dc is very
reactionary
with their film studios so it's like if
this current plan they have starts to
fail then they might go all right let's
revisit the snyder verse again let's see
what we can do
yeah but i don't wish for those movies
to
fail you know like i still want them to
do well i champion filmmakers
essentially and especially if they are
able to keep their creative integrity
when making these movies like what it
sounds like james gonna talk about with
the suicide squad that [ __ ] makes me
excited that she makes me happy if we're
talking about
snyder verse specifically you're here
scoopers and people and inside reports
talk all the time about being
anti-snyder
but then for zack snyder to just pretty
much flat out say it
that really does uh that that just hits
you know it's like seeing your dad come
home
crest fallen and you just know like ah
things aren't looking up
for rough dives because we got to be
fair here no one was able to
well not no one but most people around
the world were not able to see zack
snyder's justice league in the theaters
whereas avengers end game is the highest
grossing movie well no avatar we took it
but yeah but for a while
avengers end game was the highest
grossing movie of all time
most of the world saw that in the
theaters so you know it's understandable
if not a lot of people went back to
revisit it on a streaming platform
you know what i mean yeah so you got to
be fair in that regard
of to me i'm like it makes sense that
zack snyder's justice league had a
chance of surpassing the streaming count
worldwide against avengers end game
because the only way you could really
watch it is through streaming
yeah well and i mean that was quite
intentional from what i understand in
china because zach
snyder wanted to have a theatrical
release which warner bros apparently
declined to do
so you know they only gave the streaming
option and who knows what it might have
seen in terms of turnout and success if
they had actually had the theatrical
market
in full swing you know or at least as
full as it could be but i'm going to
maintain hope
i will i you know you just i just got to
be honest with myself when
when my feelings get a little hit when i
get a little bit of a punch
i got to be honest about that but i know
me too how many times i thought about
like quitting youtube
i'm not one to really give up so
and this is a big community thing so
it's one of those things like i just
gotta say it
to let it go well and then we'll get
back to all right
let's continue the fight now guys well
exactly and i mean there's also a
quality where i think
some of this not to say that this is all
a machination but i have to imagine like
from zack snyder's position
he knows what his influence is and so
making a statement like this i have to
feel like in some ways
if not designed to have this effect will
galvanize fans even further i mean
it kind of drives perhaps this wedge of
snyder versus warner's kind of further
which is problematic because it does
bleed onto other filmmakers and whatnot
but
at the same time i still feel like these
are all
kind of chess moves in a big public
negotiation and we'll see what happens
because right now it does read like wb
just really
is like sticking to their decision just
to be stern about it and just to like
remind you who's boss
and it doesn't seem like anyone's really
winning
i mean
i think the china numbers can make a big
difference though if this is in fact a
true report
because hollywood tends so much to china
everyone knows what the hell i'm talking
about we tend so much to the china
market and the fact that
theaters are reopening again 250 million
that is
did i read this right is it 250 million
in china alone
i believe so yeah see to me like
i feel like hollywood who would read
that be like
we got a market hey it's like if we
already didn't pay attention to it in
the u.s
yeah it's definitely there in china yeah
and that's a lot of people that's a lot
of money that's tricky
so that's a lot of money to leave on the
table yeah nielsen i guess is like the
god of all ratings and we still don't
know what those numbers were so there
could be more
or not but still there could be well
yeah yeah
this is a good sign this is a good sign
this is going to keep people active for
the car restore
restore the snyder verse
this is a good sign all right guys
suddenly i have a whole bunch of hope
again
my mind just went there when you
confront that little loss but also
the the sneaky little triumphs that can
come with it subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
hit that like button last but not least
jason the dolan was just thinking about
you
wanted to shout you out i've been
looking at your instagram stories and i
love
seeing images of you just out in public
looking like
cyborg let's say just you know like
sweats
and some kind of hoodie trying to blend
in but you can't you know why because
you're jason dolan you stand
out with your charisma and your sexy
face and that stubble that you
perpetually have that i've never
seen you without and if there's any
filmmaker i would go to bat
for to try and maintain the legitimacy
of their vision release the dolan cut i
say
of our lives where you're here
more often than we all do a massage
train or something
i know what you're saying most of the
time when you do this i blacked out what
happened you know what
jason here what's going on i love you